at aviation high school we take all your
regular academic classes english social
studies physical education but then also
we have ground operations carburetors
magnetos jet engines
this airplane behind me is my classroom
every day
i'm anna centric and i'm a student at
aviation high school and i currently go
to class at jfk airport
aviation high school is a public new
york city high school students at
aviation high school spend four to five
years working on
repairing airplanes and in the process
they get their licensing to work in the
industry from the federal aviation
administration
we have a hangar on site in our main
building where we have 17 aircraft
we've been teaching students for 81
years to work in the aviation industry
we're very proud to be the school that
certifies some of the most mechanics in
the country
the responsibility of an aircraft
mechanic is huge i have to ensure that
every single bolt every single screw
every single piece of wire is safely
secured on that aircraft prevent
anything from happening while it's in
the air
when we sign off any part it's basically
our signature that's allowing the
airplane to get into the sky and our
signature is worth gold we are letting
over 100 people on the ground get into
the sky and get to the destination
i like working with my hands i like
getting out in the world i love seeing
the work that i put in flying there
you